in a 2018 press interview director Ryan
coogler said that there was one scene in
particular that he was quote incredibly
proud of but which he simply couldn't
fit into the film sat in the wakanda and
Citadel high above the city it depicts
Okoye and wakabi and a tense verbal
confrontation over killmonger's takeover
of wakanda which has resulted in
t'challa's apparent death the two of
them both loyal to wakanda above all
else are split in regard to killmonger's
goals this is
children into this world where they
become conquerors
in an interview with the Wrath black
panther editor Michael shawver described
this terrific sequence as the one scene
that was the most heartbreaking to cut
from the film he recalled toward the end
after things go bad and killmonger is in
control and all that so we're talking
about what are they going to do what is
wakanda going to become those are two
Powerhouse actors and it was an
incredible scene with so many layers to
it boyfriend and girlfriend it was
General and her advisor all those things
that was painful